if you were to ask any boy
seven years old eight years old nine
years old
where do you want to be when you're 25
30. where do you want to be they're
going to say big house fast car
beautiful wife that's what they're gonna
say every single one and slowly the
programming of the Matrix beats this
dream out of men I will tell you a story
about me
I don't know you're not probably not old
enough but there was a game called
before fortnite before it all existed
the huge game when I was in my
late teens early 20s was Call of Duty
Modern Warfare so I used to play that
game and what and this is the advice the
advice is hang around with people who
see things people who who have a good
mindset I was with my brother and I was
like oh Andrew I just complete this
round is 41 kills one death that's
pretty cool Andrew looks at me from the
couch I swear to God looks everything
goes yeah Tristan but it doesn't matter
does it it doesn't matter does it and I
turned that game off and I don't think
I've ever spent more than 10 minutes
playing a video game ever since that day
so hang around better people you know if
you're wasting your life you're wasting
your talents leave that group of friends
cut low quality people out of your life
and slowly as you go out into the world
and apply yourself at different things
that are more useful you'll probably
find out that you're not as useless as
you think
but I do get asked to question my young
men a lot and it's always about making
money you mean you mean you want to get
rich cool let me tell you something uh
first and foremost almost no one ever
gets gets Rich the internet will preach
all this oh your time will come when the
universe thinks it's right and all this
no no no most people work their shitty
job live their shitty life uh live their
shitty old age and then they die most
people never ever get to get rich they
never get to live like Sterling and
that's the reality for most people so
first of all understand that
accident here
second of all and my advice is is
non-advice if you took a hundred people
100 millionaires at random and put them
in this room and you asked all of them
how do you make a million dollars you're
going to get 100 different answers Elon
Musk would say I invented PayPal and
Jeff Bezos would say I sold I sold books
online like you're not going to get a
definitive answer so what do you think
not necessarily what do you enjoy do
what you enjoy most of what you enjoy
about getting paid what do you think you
could be good at
sit and analyze yourself
what do you think you could be good at
ask yourself that I don't know you what
are you good at uh think about what you
think you
you and answer the question to yourself
I can't tell you that's that's my
address like look where money is moving
and stand in the way I know a dude when
I was trying I was trying to buy a part
for my car he was like oh I know someone
I know someone who who Who's got car
parts for something cheaper he heard I
had a problem he heard I was going to
spend money on a car park he jumps in
the middle probably made himself a
thousand dollars I don't care how much
he made he saved me look where money is
moving and getting them that's a good
starting position I never wanted to be a
multi-millionaire Andrew once said to me
famously Tristan we could just find a
way to make like 50 100 pounds a day
from home that would alleviate a lot of
our problems start small because as you
climb the mountain and you reach where
you wanted to reach you realize that
there are new mountains to climb there
are new mountains to climb for me right
now and I'm at a level that a lot of
people can't even dream of getting to
but you see it it opens new doors when
you accomplish the goals that you're
aiming for and uh it opens your eyes to
what's possible from there so don't
think I want to be a multi-millionaire
think okay I want some Financial
Independence I want to work 20 hours at
the fast food store instead of 40 but
supplement my income from home okay I've
done that now I have more free time
where do I go from here I've reached
that mountain I've seen what's possible
and aimed higher that's it so don't
don't think how am I going to become a
multi-millionaire think of your
short-term goals make sure your mother
works less buy yourself some nicer
clothes you know live in a better
apartment and think of how you can make
those things happen and as as you go up
in value as a man you'll learn a lot
about yourself and from then you could
tackle bigger goals
stop wasting your time so I was 17 I was
working at a fast food restaurant making
sandwiches now the internet didn't
really exist as such but looking back on
it it was part of my journey and I
regret nothing because I ended up where
I am so would I even go back and tell
myself anything
is the question if I had to
um it would be to to not burn so much of
my time let's talk to the 17 year olds
who are listening you know do you do you
finish your job come home play Video
Games Etc that's what I used to do when
I was 17 a little bit what I didn't do
is come home and think okay let's let's
work on something new let's try and
build something let's start a YouTube
channel let's start creating content
instead of consuming content
um yeah I'd tell myself to be a little
bit more proactive with my free time and
not around so much and being a gentleman
is is very very important
there doesn't have to be a winner when
you're going on a date with a woman and
you're looking to sleep with her and
she's looking to have a good time you
could both go home happy you really can
there you don't have to feel like you
defeated her somehow or you tricked her
somehow and she doesn't need to feel
like she used you somehow you could have
a wonderful evening you're nice to her
you open the car doors you know you buy
her a bouquet of flowers you have dinner
you make love you go home she's happy
you're happy it's down to you it's
personal accountability and that's what
a lot of guys want to throw out the
window these days it's like uh failing
in every business you've ever attempted
and failing to make money and then
blaming capitalism or failing in uh
failing in uh every boxing match or
every American football game and NFL
game you've ever played and blaming the
referees or blaming the rules no uh it's
personal accountability and it's
personal responsibility so I think a lot
of these guys need to really really look
in the mirror as I do and sometimes I
look at myself with interesting okay
you're a little out of shape Tristan
okay uh you know you've been you've been
sleeping too much you've been you've
been partying too hard you've got bags
under your eyes you've been you know
you're letting yourself go a bit and you
have to keep yourself in check you have
to stay at the very top and if you don't
stay at your very top you're not
competitive anymore every single species
on the whole planet is exactly the same
every single female of every single
species look at the looks at the most
competitive males and thinks those are
the ones I want to have my children and
women human women are exactly the same
so if you're not having the successful
women that you want don't go out there
trying to blame women and don't go out
there trying to change will and what
people don't want to hear is that to
become Tristan Tate was a slow process
of hard work that took me 15 years and
I'm still working on myself I think that
Tristan Tate in three or four years is
going to be a much better version of who
I am now right um and what a lot of
people want to do is you know blame
their circumstances but they don't
understand that I mean height aside you
can change every circumstance about you
you could change how handsome you are
you could change how fit you are how
strong you are how rich you are how
smart you are I am very fortunate I I
don't know what loneliness feels like
and that's something that most men can't
say and it's why me and my brother when
we understood through meeting very good
friends of ours who were married for 10
years felt alone ex-military guys who
felt that sense of Brotherhood and
loyalty and companionship in the army or
on their sports team their their college
baseball team their fraternity their
their football team and they lose it
those are the guys who who opened my
eyes to how special the relationship I
have with my brother is and that's what
I try to tell the world as well I don't
know what loneliness feels like you know
I was born in a very underprivileged
family I grew up absolutely broke I
didn't have the best I wasn't dealt the
best hand but there was always an ace up
my sleeve so I don't know what that
feels like I've always had companionship
I've always had someone who had my back
someone to fight with me someone to work
with me in terms of my brother so I'm
not going to sit here and say that the
the journey to the top for me
necessarily was lonely but let me tell
the young man out there you need to be
able to identify low quality friends and
cut them off and curate the people
around you into a group of winners a
group of men who want to go out there
and achieve the same things as you and
the journey to the top not only won't be
lonely but it will be far easier
[Music]